is this normal to vaccinate people who
are not at risk of a disease to protect
other people is that normally done no
this is the first time it's been
suggested
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a fascinating
guest we have for you today he is a
consultant oncologist he's a professor
of medicine at the university of
buckingham and most important of all a
returning guest to the show dr carricola
welcome back thank you very much it's so
good to have you back on the show it's
been about a year since we last had you
on to talk about lockdown and covet and
we didn't really get into vaccines i
think much of the time
what have you made of the last year and
everything that's been going on well
it's been fairly fast-paced not what i
expected i mean going into lockdown and
when it began was easy it was easy for
the politicians it was easy for those
that implemented it getting out is much
more complex and that's what we're
seeing now we're seeing the tail end of
getting out of it and you know the
ridiculous business of the different
four countries having different rules
within the uk
and uh and yet anyone can travel between
them so the rules are sort of nonsense
basically but i think now we're in a
very good position the number of
hospital admissions has fallen the
number of cases has fallen and we seem
to be getting out of the third wave
the pessimists the gloomy boys say and
girls say what about the fourth wave and
you know if there is anything it'll just
be a little blip that's my reading of
the situation well what about winter
surely there's going to be another peak
in winter and i don't say this to
someone who's in any way desperate for
that to happen it's more that i think
it's been a year and a half of of these
constant expectations and you're known
for your positivity of course you are
and i think last time we talked you were
hopeful that this would be over by
previous january but that hasn't
transpired so the concern for i think
for everybody is that as winter comes
there will be pressures whether they're
covered or not there's always pressure
on the nhs and the feeling i think is
given the public sentiment which i find
difficult to explain frankly at this
point uh we will be in another lockdown
don't you think that that's likely well
if it was due to cover yes but it's not
likely to be due to code it's like to be
due to other viruses and secondary
pneumonia it happens every winter you
know i was a medical student many many
years ago and when i came out of the
book work and went to the wards the
first year there was a flu epidemic and
it was chaos the whole awards no routine
operations everything canceled
because of flu and
mainly elderly patients got a bit of an
infection with the virus and then they
got secondary pneumonia and some of them
ended up on ventilators
and that happens every year we call it
winter pressures in the nhs it's a
euphemism no other country has winter
pressures it's a it's a failure to have
the capacity to deal with it
and therefore you have to shut down
services such as routine
non-urgent surgery to make beds to make
facilities available to make intensive
care available for those that need it
because of the infection so will we
actually get coronavirus causing a
problem in the winter
perhaps in a small way but it's much
more likely there are a whole row of
other things coming along flu other
coronaviruses that will
dominate and cause the winter pressures
and of course that's great
uh so so so i guess what i'm saying is
i'm just
uh you you you're positive that this is
the tail end of it
but i i do should people should people
be positive about it i think they should
we've got to learn to live with this we
can't have this nonsense just this week
about traveling i mean you know either
you go for it and you say that's it
we're opening things up or you you don't
you can't suddenly say oh this country's
just become red on sunday and so unless
you get back by sunday you're stuck and
this is mexico where there's quite a lot
of tourists have gone
and these people are desperate i mean
you know it costs an awful lot to
organize your own trip home ver on a
commercial airliner so and they don't
get any help from their existing
provider of transport so i think it's
that sort of thing that's really
irritating we've got to come out of it
in a smooth way instead of a sort of
a jagged way which leaves bad taste and
then the rest of society
you know there's lots of illogicality
and the biggest one i was in wales yes a
day before yesterday wales has different
rules so they're still
with masks everywhere with uh social
distancing uh no one's enforcing it but
they they they have that rule so i went
to a little restaurant for a curry with
a colleague and uh you have to wear a
mask to go from the door it's a tiny
little place no bigger than the studio
here and uh you had to wear a mask to go
through the door you sat down you take
the mask off and this has seemed
ridiculous that you know for 10 yards
you wore a mask then you took it off and
the way obviously the staff all will
mask so
it's these sort of rules that are not
based on any real science that seem to
be still lingering and will probably
linger way until christmas as people
still don't get totally relaxed about
the virus basically
do you sometimes worry carol that with
the lockdowns we've opened the pandora's
box so you say that
every winter the nhs comes under
pressure because of capacity the
government's going to say right well
the nhs we need to protect the nhs let's
shut everything down again
that certainly is a worry that you use
the experience of the last year anything
that comes along whether it's winter or
not you say oh let's shut down again and
you do a dramatic shutdown
the other way is to say let's expand the
nhs expand healthcare
not necessarily in the same form as
we've got it now and develop places that
people can go that have chest infections
and
you know when you look at it the problem
we've got you've got hospitals which are
expensive 500 pound a night for a bed in
a hospital anywhere in the country
because of the staff costs
and you've got care homes which have no
medical care no qualified nurses usually
maybe
the head head person there is a nurse
but on the whole they have no medical
facilities and they don't want you
they're commercial they're all private
and uh
so that there's only two choices what we
need is the third choice in the middle
for older people they can go there and
they can get medical care of a light
version not intravenous strips and not
ventilators and things but they can stay
there and be looked after whilst they
get better well enough to go to the care
home with no medical care so it's a
matter of it's called uh you know step
down accommodation but we just don't
really have any in this country who runs
it the nhs or the private sector it
really doesn't matter and it could be
free at the point of delivery so that's
the key to it all care homes are not
free of course i mean some people get
them through but you have to have very
little money if you've got a house
you're going to have to pay for your
care home so that's the problem
and carol we're talking about the nhs
and it seems that the nhs as long as
i've been alive we've been talking how
it's in crisis
but it does seem to be in crisis at the
moment particularly when you look at
waiting lists particularly when you look
at the effects that kovid has had on the
nhs
i think the the reason cove is impinged
on our healthcare system compared to
other european systems is simply
capacity
you know waiting lists and rationing
have been there i've been a consultant
40 years and we've had it all the time
and uh you know just to get an mr scan a
magnetic resonance scan if you've got
backache or a knee problem or even if
you've got sort of weight weight loss
and abdominal pain it can take six
months and everyone accepts it and so
whereas in france you'd go
within two days you'd have the scan
there's the capacity in the system which
we don't have so building up that
capacity is clearly something that we
can learn from code it and and it came
suddenly and of course nobody really
knows how many people are on the waiting
list it's amazing the figures vary
there's probably more than the
government figures 5.3 million at the
moment but there's almost certainly more
if you take everything including scans
and
blood tests and so on and and we sort of
accepted a very sluggish system uh gp
hospital and the jeep to get to see your
gp can take six weeks now so just
imagine you've got a you know
you may have cancer and you have to wait
six weeks before you start then you get
to the gp then you have to have a blood
test you wait two weeks for that then
you get referred for an mr scan you wait
another six weeks or even two months but
even for an urgent one so it's all that
waiting that we have here that other
countries have avoided by having more
capacity and why is that carol because
you know the people on the left go it's
a funding problem the people on the
right go you know the fact that the nhs
is bloated it's misspending what is the
truth
it's it's between the two it is
underfunded for what could be achieved
with modern medicine it's also
challenged by old people people older
than me that's my definition
and uh
people older than me are big consumers
of it and they
all of it from gp to hospital care and
so on and often there's not much health
systems can do for old people they're
just they have chronic comorbidities and
generally body crumble and
you know you're stuck with that
for younger people it's episodic care
which is what they want you have to
define procedure for doing something
that's hernia or
you know cataracts and so on you get
that done the problem we've got is that
the nhs
is also a political tool and it's very
much bloated with
middle management that want to be
politically correct and for example
two months ago i had to do my yearly
appraisal and to do that you have to do
mandatory training online and it
involves all sorts of things uh you know
uh courses on fire extinguishers well i
can i can see the use of violence of
course just in case i can see that but
uh you know to have to learn about
equality and diversity i understand the
problems of equality and diversity but
you know to spend an hour going through
it i mean it's sort of almost religious
and i was brought up as a roman catholic
so i'm used to cataclysmic learning when
people tell you this is what you have to
do
and this is the right way and so you
have to go through all that and someone
has to supervise it and ironically most
of these training courses are outsourced
to the private sector so it's it's
almost ridiculous that we all have to do
this but i think throughout the nhs
there's a sort of a cult of a religion
there and you know we saw it with the
banging of spoons in kovitch and that's
a sort of almost religious act that
you're praising your priests the high
priests of the nhs
and uh
you know you can say what what people
are praising of course is the the
medical nursing staff they're not
praising the structure and that's the
problem they have to dissociate that and
try and move forward
and uh you talk about the priest class
which i think is actually a very
important conversation but there's been
another area in which i feel that that's
been happening which you alluded to
earlier which is this notion that every
restriction that we that has been
imposed on the country every decision
that's been made it's all been
following the science which is a phrase
that irritates me massively because from
what i know about the science both my
parents are scientists the science is
about discussion and debate and
different points of view and testing
hypotheses and sometimes being wrong and
being able to admit it
the idea that the science has one
particular view it is frankly absurd yet
that has been the messaging what have
you made of that i think we've seen the
politicians on one side trying to
implement the advice they're getting
from committees
and sage is the main committee
but there are little subcommittees and
it's very difficult i mean the
committees work
they take the data and
maybe 20 people on stage on the
committee obviously just doing it
virtually
and so you get one or two people that
are very negative and want to have you
know severe lockdown
vaccinate everybody including babies all
this sort of stuff everyone has to wear
masks everywhere and
so they tend to dominate the thinking of
the group so it's called group think and
they they convert people and everyone
wants the committee to come to an end so
you have to get some sort of consensus
and so the consensus tends to go with
the severest option goes down if you
remove two or three people that are
doing that you'd have a much more
balanced view
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
ridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anthony has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge are such
great guys they're gonna give you 10 off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash
trigger and use our special code which
is of course trigger
the other beef i've got about it is the
data is not disclosed so great example
last week
the vaccinating 16 and 7 year old 17
year olds so okay it's a valid point if
the risk of getting
covered would lead to more illness then
vaccination provided it doesn't cause a
lot of side effects
it would be justified but you you know
where's the data show us how you've come
to that conclusion and there was nothing
that this was a commit a subcommittee
called the joint committee of vaccines
and immunization and you know it's been
around for years and they've looked at
how to do schedules for mumps and for
measles and polio and so on now they're
stuck with coving and uh
immunizing the 16 and 17 year olds is a
valid point but let's see the risk
benefit analysis and it's not public and
so we don't really know so all these gps
are going to have to go out and collect
up the 16 to 17 roles and and shoot them
up with vaccine
without really knowing if it's
if the risks of the vaccine outweigh the
risks of getting covert because they're
not a group they get ill with governed
on the whole they get covered but not
and you know the the ethos
that's not good is it that gps are going
to be vaccinating people without really
knowing whether the risk was worth it
absolutely a good thing is it
it you know i've asked them to publish
the data but they they won't and you
know one suspect the data are not muddy
because you know the vaccine and it's
only the fisa vaccine that's going to be
allowed so the fact that the fisa
vaccine is probably the best studied of
the vaccines because it was the trials
in the states and in south america were
right at the very beginning and they
included young people including children
carol sorry can i just interrupt why is
it they're only going to give the fisa
vaccine to the kids and not the
astrazeneca okay so the astrazeneca
don't doesn't go to anybody below 40 at
the moment and the reason is that the
astrazeneca has a side effect profile
which is age related in other words if
you're over 40 you don't get the side
effects if you're under 40 the side
effects on the heart and on the lungs
are more severe with with the the
vaccine all vaccines have you know
severe side effects but in very small
numbers of people even polio has side
effects uh the polio vaccine the polio
vaccine has side effects and
and yet but it's very low and the
consequences of polio are very bad for a
child they they get they can be
paralyzed and
you know when i was a youngster you
could see people that had polio they
were limping around with a bad leg and
calipers and so on that's all gone for a
society because of the vaccine but
coming back to sars
the problem there is that you're going
to immunize an age group that really is
not troubled by the infection if they
get it very few are going to be in
hospital very few are going to be on a
ventilator
so the ethicists love the situation
because they say one of the reasons they
want to vaccinate kids is because you're
protecting the older people
so you're vaccinating you're putting at
risk a young person so an older person
can live well the older person has now
been double vaccinated so why should
this help i mean it's in a logical area
and that's why it'd be good to see the
data on these sort of decisions other
countries have the same mess i mean it's
not just us sure so the united states
everybody over 12 is being offered the
vaccine and the data's just not there
for that carol what do you make of this
because it's not something that francis
and i know about and these are real
questions i think a lot of people want
to hear the answer to
is this normal to vaccinate people who
are not at risk of a disease to protect
other people is that normally done no
this is the first time it's been
suggested really and that's why i'd be
very keen to see the day forget the
protection business see
what's the risk benefit analysis
on on the patient on on on the child on
the 16 year old what benefit do they get
i mean you know the story is all it well
it's september's coming up they're going
to go back to school or back to college
and the you know boys and girls at 16 to
17 social distancing is not part of
their agenda and they'll go dancing and
so on so they need protection but if the
risk is greater than the the benefit we
shouldn't be doing it and so that's the
sort of analysis you want to see right
and you know it's alright saying this is
our conclusion accept it without the
data well that's wrong we should be able
to see the data but it's never been done
what about smallpox didn't that get
eradicated by the vacuum vaccination
smallpox was a great smallpox and polio
are the best success stories ever
because they were lethal diseases
you know the story of smallpox
vaccination goes back nearly 300 years
and
cowpox it was noted by jenna the the
edward janna the founder of vaccinology
really that the milk maids that have the
cow pox didn't get smallpox there was a
cross-reaction and so he went round
vaccinating people wacker comes from the
word cow latin i think
way back from my o-level days
so taking the cow pox and put it
scratching it into the arms of not
milkmaids but everybody and that was in
fact what was fascinating about jenna 20
years before there was a guy called
benjamin jeste he wasn't a medic he was
a farmer in yet minister
and which is a small village
in somerset
and he did the same thing with his
family and others around him and so he
was but he got no credit for it he's got
a blue plaque on his house because i've
been there the farmhouse he had
but he got no credit for it jenna got
the credit because he was a physician
his portraits up in the royal college of
physicians whereas uh
our friend benjamin jeste was just the
blue plaque on his farmhouse
but no the whole business of vaccination
is fascinating because you're taking
normal they're not patients right people
that are normal
as we are the three of us sitting in the
studio
and so you're going to do an
intervention that must by definition
carry risks
for their benefit
can you do the same thing for other
people's benefit and that's that's the
question you're really that's what i'm
getting at because to me look i'm not a
medical ethicist but the ethics of that
surely are questionable aren't they they
are and so that's why the data from jcvi
on
what benefit what's the risk benefit to
the person you're vaccinating forget
what benefit on the population and is
there not another way i mean if if
16 year old it could do social
distancing from his grandparents for
example and there's other ways of
protecting the grandparents and you know
one of the problems of the whole
immunization business it's voluntary
there's no compulsion and it's the same
for childhood vaccination as you know
with andrew wakefield and all that data
about autism and vaccines a lot of
people stopped immunizing their kids and
that has led to an increase in the
number of children with measles and
mumps and
rubella and things like that because
parents have just avoided getting
vaccination that's sort of disappearing
now with this
it's giving vaccination a bad name for
the reasons you just suggested that if
you can't see the data why are we doing
it
and it's a very very very good point and
you were saying that you know we don't
coerce people into taking vaccines we're
kind of doing it now aren't we carol
well it's very clever game you know i
think there's some very smart people in
number 10 that are sitting there looking
at how to persuade people to be
vaccinated these are guys that have been
to top universities they're very bright
and they've come up with this idea that
what we did was to drip it in we don't
say vaccine passports are going to be
compulsory we just drip it in and then
you remove it but because you're
dripping it in and the pr comes out
you're going to have to have a vaccine
passport i mean how's it really going to
be implemented a vaccine passport to go
in the pub at the end of the road who's
going to check it who's going to be able
to validate that what you're showing is
yours and all the rest of it it's much
more complex crossing international
borders is easy because you've got
trained people that can look at
documents you can
insist on various things but going down
to the king and queen at the end of the
road that's not the real problem
you know this is a different level so i
think that you know the smart guys in
number 10 have got a plan that you just
keep going with it people then get
vaccinated
and then you remove the need for any
certification because you succeed in the
great thing about all vaccines you don't
need to do the whole population
if you do 80 percent that's good enough
and of course we're already at about 80
percent immunity because a lot of people
have covets so you've got the infected
and you've got the vaccinated people and
both of them will have immunity and so
that stops the spread so it reduces the
r number of the of spread well let's go
into the whole vaccine passport thing
francis sorry just one thing i know i've
been hogging the mic i just wanted to
say one thing on that particular issue
which is the counter argument to
everything you've said that we we keep
hearing and i'd love for you to address
this is the idea that if there's a small
unvaccinated population then that will
be the breeding ground for new variants
which will then reinfect and and
sabotage the whole program what do you
make of that argument i think that's
unlikely simply because uh if you
destroy the roots of communication
transmission for the virus you destroy
the the chances of a mutant getting out
into the immune people there's very
little evidence that once you're
vaccinated you're going to get infected
even with mutants so if a mutant arises
an unvaccinated patient unvaccinated
people it's unlikely that it can
transmit back to your immune population
aren't we seeing people in hospital with
covered having been double jab now
a few but it's mainly people that
haven't been double jab that go into
hospital that serious illness is
prevented by the vaccines and that
there's no doubt what's not prevented by
the vaccine necessarily is the is the
transmission especially
after just one job but on the whole the
vaccinated population protects the
unvaccinated population so there is
again this sort of uh
you know it's it's a strange business um
and if you look at it's we've never had
it before because if you look at things
like polio that doesn't the the vaccines
are perfect compared to sales but
vaccine which is not perfect it's you
know 80 percent effective so 20 you're
getting no benefit for so that's the
trouble with it all and people play
around with those numbers i mean you
know i'm not an immunologist but i know
enough to understand that
it's so to say well the prize of vaccine
is 95 percent effective what does that
really mean
you really love to do the experiment you
get 100 people you give them the shot
and then you infect them deliberately
and you see who how many get it then you
take another 100 people no vaccine shoot
them up you know and they all get it and
and that's the number you really want to
do the comparison but that would be an
unethical experiment so going back to
the idea of vaccine passports there's a
lot of people who will say
that
those people are putting others at risk
in an event in a concert etc etc we
can't have them in that area
this is how we protect people do you
agree with that argument no i think you
can do it alternatively you can do
testing we've got very good rapid tests
now uh lateral flow tests which sure
there's false positives there's false
negatives but they're really not bad and
i think that should be enough to gain
your entrance to wembley or some big
event
i think it's interesting i noticed that
an advert for cruising i've never been
on a cruise and i never want to go on a
cruise by the way
saga cruises and it said everyone has to
be vaccinated so it was in the advert
for the cruise it said vaccine people
only or something like that i know
that's an interesting
exactly what you say people feel more
secure if everyone's been vaccinated on
the boat but much better to test
everybody as they go onto the boat the
trouble with that is what you do people
you sell hampton docks and someone tests
positive
you're stuck they've got to take their
luggage back they've got to go they'll
be really very
distraught about the situation so that
is the problem with testing but you
could test before they leave the house i
mean there's ways of doing it and there
are lots of around the corner from your
studio the place that says testing
same-day service and
everywhere you can get these things
wouldn't you agree as well carol that
the introduction of vaccine passports or
the threatened introduction of vaccine
passports actually heightened suspicion
amongst people who are worried about the
vaccine
it does and that's why
mandatory making it mandatory is
probably the wrong approach now a lot of
arguments within healthcare whether you
can make mandatory vaccination of staff
and that is a really difficult issue and
we were all very privileged to be
offered vaccination right at the
beginning i got mine the first week of
january i went round to hammersmith my
old hospital and
eight o'clock in the morning coffee in a
bun and shoot up and you know so we but
there are a group of people that just
don't want it whatever reason they just
don't want it now can you insist that
they don't work front line with patients
if they're going to insist on that what
use are they to you because if they
can't a nurse can't be on a ward what
are you going to do make her an
administrator or something i mean
there's not that many roles for people
that are you know front line clinical to
go behind because they won't be
vaccinated so much better to try and
persuade them to be vaccinated or to
you know does it really matter that it's
back to following the science that you
mentioned constantine we don't have the
we don't really know if a small
percentage say 10 percent of your staff
are not vaccinated are they going to be
a problem in dealing with patients
because obviously patient safety is
paramount in any healthcare system care
home is the same and so can you immunize
all the staff to prevent them being a
rooted transmission
and i think you can persuade them to be
without making it compulsory do you
think it's illogical for people to be
fearful of this vaccine i'll give you an
example my girlfriend's 32 years old she
had the astrazeneca it's now said that
you should be over the age of 40 to have
astrazeneca there's countries that have
said that band astrazeneca for a certain
period of time
is it what is it logical for people to
be concerned about this vaccine and not
want to take it if you're looking at the
science and the data
i think
the astrazeneca has a different toxicity
profile side effect profile than the
pfizer
on the other hand it's a much more
established way of making a vaccine
taking a another virus and coupling it
up with some proteins that it expresses
to make it look as though it's a sales
virus to the immune system
uh the pfizer is just a little bit of
rna which is the message that dna makes
protein with and so you it's a sort of
genetic engineering if you like you're
putting a gene an artificial gene in the
arm which is going to turn over proteins
that again convince the immune system
you've already been infected and
therefore develop a powerful resistance
if you do get exposed to the virus so
you know the side effect profiles are
different and what's emerged in the
clinical trials is the pfizer seems to
have less side effects in younger people
than the astrazeneca and that's the
reason for the age cut off other
countries have made it 60 rather than 40
so scandinavian countries won't give
astrazeneca under 60 to try and avoid
this and the most serious problems are
in the heart the brain and the lung and
it's inflammation it's non-specific
inflammatory change um most cases it's
transient
you know two or three weeks it gets
better but in some it doesn't and that's
that's the worry and there have been
deaths but there are deaths with both
vaccines the real trouble with
relating anything to a vaccine is you
know people are primed when they get the
vaccine anything that goes wrong they
blame the vaccine and
and it may have happened anyway and you
can't separate that
then how do you convince these people
who are worried of which i'll be honest
with you i am one of them yeah because i
like you said i i saw the way that they
changed continually i and i i was
thinking at one point do i take the a-z
oh i can't take the a-z
how do you convince people then but also
francis you've had covered right yeah
and i've had but i've had covid so i
think to
myself should i take it should i not
take it i've had covered i see i was
fine with it i felt rough for a week but
then i got over it do i need the vaccine
the answer is
francis nobody knows what to advise an
individual and that's where we are that
we can't advise an individual we can
look the whole population and look at
the the benefit in terms of preventing
covid related illness and then
including long covet and then we can
look at the uh the risks of having the
vaccine and they're in someone of your
age they're relatively small whether
it's astrozenic or pharma they're almost
trivial but if you do get bad side
effects they're not going to be trivial
that's the problem
so
the advice for populations is get
immunized how we persuade people i mean
i think it's crazy persuading people by
giving monetary offerings and a hundred
dollars in the states and so on or a big
mac have a big mac this seemed that
counterintuitive as a health
gift to have
with chips yeah yeah
and a nice fizzy fizzy high calorie
drink to go with it so
bribing people doesn't work they have to
understand and i think the other thing
we've not spent enough time is working
out why people are scared what what the
reasons for it but you know it's still
very sad there are families that don't
the mothers won't let their kids have
polio for example vaccination and that
that seems a little strange in the
modern world but people have different
beliefs and i guess
my training within the nhs for
diversities means you have to encompass
all beliefs and
not force things through i mean in a
sense lockdown
uh was forced through although our
lockdown in the uk was very light
compared with a lot of other countries
which
used police police and military in a
much more aggressive way to keep people
you know that you got shot if you came
to the door you know that's something
and uh
but you know you were certainly accosted
to know why you were moving around
whereas here it was yeah it was almost
voluntary
and you you talk about the the lockdowns
and the sort of various measures
have you been concerned by
the the government's willingness to
coerce people into doing things whether
that's
you know taking the vaccine or or
whatever other measures that they're
encouraging
the thing that's really concerned me
about it is is the willingness of the
government in a free society to use you
know boris johnson saying oh well if you
want to enjoy life you're going to have
to get the to me that that's it's quite
a forceful way of doing things isn't it
yeah i really don't like it civil
liberty is really important and
we've seen that go a bit but as i say
the uk has not been the worst country
and we call these interventions mpis
non-pharmacological intervention it's
not a vaccine it's not a drug uh it's
social distancing it's mask wearing and
it's lockdown i mean
avoiding crowds shutting restaurants
shutting all these things and you know
all these rules these bubbles i never
understood the bubbles and why
restaurants wouldn't take more than six
people because otherwise you'd be
breaking the rules i i just couldn't get
my head around those and again they
varied in wales and london and glasgow
and so on so
the enforcement is not easy and you know
i felt sorry for the police i mean they
were trying to enforce it and now and
again you get some heavy-handed you know
episodes happening
a couple of ladies walked around a
reservoir somewhere and they got
arrested and fined for having a cup of
coffee there and that sort of thing is
bad taste and
you know i remember seeing a picture of
a roadblock somewhere in the west
country and they were looking in the
boot to see if you'd been shopping you
had to show your shopping because you
know but this is ridiculous i mean it's
uh uh so i and i i think that's been the
problem um that
no one wants it and i think you have to
persuade people that vulnerable people
need to be they're older people people
with existing chest disease
who if they do get covered are going to
get it bad they should avoid restaurants
they should just not go out but you and
me we can go out because we're healthy i
mean that's the sort of way i'd look at
it what do you make of the counter
argument to that that people make very
often because you know the conversation
the three of us are having here is not
representative of the public mood of the
deposit to be believed right so
the counter argument that people often
make is well you talk about your civil
liberties carol but actually by being in
a restaurant let's say me and francis
who both had covered but haven't had the
vaccine yeah
you are denying me my civil liberty to
be in a restaurant because i have to be
afraid for my health what about that
argument isn't that a reasonable way of
looking at it it's a very interesting
point and you know i travel in from the
suburbs from where i live and i come on
the train and
i don't wear a mask but nearly everyone
else is wearing a mask i've noticed now
why are they wearing a mask some of them
probably think they're protecting
themselves so that's that's a
misconception but that they want to
believe it's protecting them to feel
better with it why not let them do it
others think it's their civil duty and
in fact
on the railway sign it says please be
considerate wear a mask uh it would help
if you wear a mask in crowded places how
do you define a crowded place you know
obviously london underground has been
crowded throughout this whole thing and
the central line is particularly bad and
a lot of people have never worn a mask
on that so
it's it's a very difficult issue and
again it's civil liberties do what you
want
the other thing that's fascinating that
very few people seem to be aware is the
exemption
and
the exemption is just ridiculous anyone
can be exempt you don't have to go to a
doctor you don't have to go anywhere you
just can phone up or
email transport for london and they'll
send you a badge i mean it is
and you can cut one out from the website
and you can declare yourself exempt i
mean it's it's just crazy uh and there
are all these inconsistencies
in in the whole system and i think you
know the business that you
even during the beginning of lockdown we
allowed people to walk a dog so
well this is just either you have
lockdown or you don't they allow people
to go shopping you allow you know other
countries didn't you know
my granddaughter lives in peru and the
store is sheep towels well
obviously it's a bit of a military
police state there
and they do have a serious problem with
kobe and there you walked out and police
would come and find you and take you
back and you know go and tell your
parents off it's a different
system francis do you want to learn
another language no mate i'm english if
foreigners can't understand me i just
shout at them think about it you could
learn how to say penalties in italian
leave it but if you do want to learn
another language because maybe you want
to have new experiences live in another
country or maybe you just want to open
your mind my mind's open enough if i
open it up any further my brain's going
to hurt this is true but babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
they design their courses with practical
real world conversations in mind
sentences you will use in normal
everyday life sentences like oi pedro
dos services paul
thank you francis and bible's courses
have been proven to be scientific
and bible's courses have been proven to
be scientifically effective across
multiple studies their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go it's available as an
app or online and your progress will be
synced across all devices you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
they've also got their own podcast
so you can brush up on your french and
spanish on the go start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and before you know it
hablar espanol absolutamente perfecto
now i mean gary right now babel is
offering our listeners six months free
with a purchase of a six-month
subscription with our promo code which
is of course trigger go to uk.babel.com
play and use promo code trigger for an
extra six months free that's uk
dot b a b b e l dot c o m forward slash
play
promo code trigger
the civil liberty side always worries me
but what also worries me is the effect
that this has had on cancer patients
and stopping
the system
for lockdown what is it what effect does
that had on you and your department and
the cancer departments across the
country huge effect and that was one of
the one of the reasons i got a twitter
account was to point this out right at
the beginning that cancer patients are
going to suffer here and what happened
way back in april 2020 and so more than
a year ago was suddenly the whole
system's ground to halt so you couldn't
go and see your gp
the gp couldn't refer you to the
hospital you couldn't get even a chest
x-ray was difficult to arrange even if
you were coughing up blood you couldn't
get a chest x-ray which would diagnose
tuberculosis or lung cancer so even if
i presented at the jupiter and saying
look i'm physically coughing up blood
which is a classic sign of lung cancer
yeah
nothing would happen and there's a good
paper in the british medical journal
pointing that out that people with
hemoptysis which is coughing up blood in
medical terms
were ignored
in april and may and the the best
evidence there was a serious problem was
looking at the number of biopsies for
cancer so biopsy putting a needle
somewhere and taking a sample and that's
how you know someone's got cancer it's
the only way you can really tell i mean
x-rays and scans do help you but it
doesn't it's not convincing that that
really is cancer the shadow they have
normal shadows of cancer so the biopsy
level the number of biopsies per day
should be around a thousand every day
so
and you look at the numbers they dropped
to about 50 during april and to about
200 in may and then they gradually came
up as the year went on but even now
access to certain services are limited
because
you know if you've got a waiting list of
five million probably more in there
there are cancer patients that don't
know they've got cancer nor do the
doctors know they've got cancer but once
whatever the procedure they're waiting
for is done cancer will be diagnosed
i've got a couple of questions for you
on on that particular issue the first
one again the counter argument to what
you're saying is well look if we didn't
do a lockdown if we didn't take all
these measures the nhs would have been
overwhelmed and you still have a massive
backlog but also loads of people are
dying of cover it isn't didn't we need
to do all of that to just stop the
system from collapse
i would say no
it was finally balanced especially with
the second wave but
this way there's no effect i mean the
number of people going into hospitals
not flooding it at all
the second wave was a bit different and
the the it was getting close now the
other interesting thing is how difficult
it is to predict what's going to happen
at any point in time with this so it's
very easy to look back and say oh we
should have done this we should have
done that but at the time you couldn't
work out where the curves were going and
the government's politicians are easily
swayed by extreme views extremely
negative views about where it's going
you know
the one thing that was quite amazing and
what a waste of money it was with the
nightingale hospitals
in building these places like one close
to here in excel in london and no one
seemed to give any thought to where the
staff were coming from where you're
going to get the people they're in the
hospitals they're busy they've got jobs
to do and uh what you're gonna
getting retired doctors retired nurses
you know some of my friends signed up
for that my wife signed up she's a nurse
but they never got used and
quite frankly they would need to be
retrained in you know in if you're doing
intensive care in excel you'd have to be
retrained to do it you couldn't just
take old people like my wife if you'll
hate me for saying that
and and sort of give them a couple of
hours and say there they go on the
ventilator unit and so they were never
used and there was
a tokenism they put a few patients to
recover in there and then closed it down
and but it must have cost a billion
pounds at least for the building that
system and you know i remember seeing a
brigadier in full camouflage kit you
know with a stick um pointing out what
how they were building this and doing
it's so easy to do that as long as
you've got money it's so easy to create
things it's much more difficult to run
them because you know in healthcare it's
staff it's always the problem and
not really doctors it's it's
who's going to be there all the time
healthcare assistance you need people
that know how to do things and that
wasn't thought through
so my second question then is the other
side which is and it's a very sad
question but
we obviously understand from what you're
saying that
there will be a backlog of cancer
patients
many of whom have not been diagnosed yet
many of whom and we know people like
this and we get messages every day as
i'm sure you do
by god i'm sure you do but people whose
cancer went from being a small lump that
was easily curable to full stage four
incurable inoperable deadly cancer
what will be the cost do you think of of
all of this
in terms of cancer deaths but also of
course you then have to heart disease
and all of that but just
the the thing that i i've never
understood and i've said this to people
every journalist i know i said why are
you not asking the politicians how many
people died from lockdown why have we
never had that conversation
what what is your take on that whole
thing i kept trying during the the the
height of lockdown to convince people
we've got to get the cancer patients out
we've got to get the heart attack people
and the stroke people
fast-tracked into hospital and if you're
waiting for your hip to be replaced you
can wait but
if you've got cancer you can't and the
story of cancer is very straightforward
you know the four common cancers are
lung breast colon and prostate
and
if you've got a stage one cancer which
means the cancer is confined to the
organ it can usually be cured with
either surgery or radiotherapy or both
and
the chances of the cure are 90 for stage
one cancer once it starts spreading to
the lymph nodes and then beyond the
lymph nosis stage two three and then
four more widespread to the lung to the
liver and so on the chances drop to less
than ten percent chance of cure so you
go from 90 cure to 10 cure the time it
takes to get there is very variable
depending on the speed of growth of the
cancer the type of cancer and so on but
a rough rule is that three months
probably drops your stage in other words
you and six months drops you to your
stages so you go from
what the lawyers love to do for cases of
litigation cases of delay on the balance
of probability
you would survive your cancer if it's 90
percent or if it's stage one to the
balance of probability you're going to
die from your cancer if it's stage three
or four so you drop that within three to
six months and
that was the problem now we won't really
know until another couple of years goes
by so by 2023 and so on and when we look
back at the cancer survival and we'll
see a
a
a blip in the patients that presented
during lockdown because they couldn't
access care
just in the same way we'll see it for
people that have heart attacks there was
a
and a lot of people it's not just
services weren't there they were too
scared to go to hospitals so they sat at
home with chest pain or they sat at home
coughing up blood because they were too
scared to use the house so also they
were
psychologically
sort of
corrupted if you like by the slogans
protect the nhs stay home save lives
your life's not important you're staying
at home to protect other lives and that
was the you know it's very clever again
these smart guys in number 10 came up
with that and they're always three
little slogans in the strap line and
very powerful messaging and what we see
now now we're coming out is that people
are still
psychologically brainwashed into the old
thinking doesn't the government need to
take responsibility for that though if
you've got someone literally at home
dying of a heart attack and they're too
terrified to come in because they're
worried about covert because the
government has given them a
disproportionate fear
it's basic common sense that you know
that a heart attack is far more
dangerous and covered it is but you know
if you've convinced people to stay home
and protect the nhs
the threshold at which they'll call for
help is raised considerably and that's
been the problem whether it's cancer or
heart attack or stroke the threshold has
changed and so we've got to get it back
we've got to get people back into the
system but that's going to take a lot of
convincing if you've essentially given
them a diet of fear of propaganda of
fear for 18 months how do you undo that
and people are so fearful i mean again
it's back to the mask wearing on the
train and and people are avoiding me
because i haven't got a mask and you
know this sort of thing they're still
very scared and these people are double
vaccinated you know
and uh yet they're they're still so
scared we've got to remove that and sort
of embrace it like we embrace the flu we
just live with it you know someone goes
off work for the flu that's fine they
come about a week later and we get back
to work
but we
this is different somehow this is a
you know
the fear factor is much greater for
kovic carol speaking of fear uh you
you're obviously an optimistic cheery
guy francis and i are not um
in you know in your quiet moments when
you you're just you've got a minute to
yourself
do you ever wonder if we're ever going
to get back to normal
i think
the population here and in other
countries has really been badly hit
psychologically it's going to take a
long time it's going to take
probably two or three years and even
then will we get back in other words
will
air travel still need pcr tests
beforehand and afterwards this sort of
thing
you know bureaucracy creates jobs for
bureaucrats and they won't want to give
up they want to carry on doing it just
like immigration controls and all the
work permits the whole bureaucracy
around that uh i can't see it going away
very soon and it's you're right it'll
it'll last
at least for two years maybe even longer
and the fear factor here i i bet even
after christmas people will be still
wearing masks on the train because
they're scared and they think the mask
is going to help
but it's great it's like having a worry
beads in the arabic nations they all go
with worry bees and they play with them
uh the same thing with the mask if you
want to wear it why not
so just wrapping up then
do you think we need a public inquiry
after this to find out not least because
we need to know what to do next time
it's not the last pandemic
interesting
we do need to do something we need to
have a review
publicly quite there's no point using it
to find fault with the politicians
because they're incompetent you can see
they're incompetent i mean why would a
journalist uh in the spectator and other
journals like that become prime minister
i mean it makes no sense and why is that
training to be prime minister
and
the same for all of them in in reality
uh they're there for
not for their skill set uh and they've
got very smart people that advise them
but now and again it goes wrong so i
think going forward
what we need to do is work out
the various bits that went wrong
and how we can avoid them if it happens
again and of course we have to broaden
it from sars it's got to be any
infectious agent it could be some ebola
it could be which is much more loss of
fever anything like that that comes into
the country and uh how we can protect
against it and implement a a plan
it's it's a very very good point because
i don't know about you do you think
we're going to enter a stage where we
see more pandemics now or do you think
it's going to be and i know it's a it's
a ridiculous question almost to ask but
yeah do you think it we're going to say
which one yeah yeah yeah it is it is
just stop asking
for us
do you think we we're going to be seeing
more pandemics as we go on
i i think the threshold again for
pandemic fear is is lowered in other
words as soon as if you remember way
back uh
in 20
2012 we had the mers and then in 2003
and 2004 we had the sar the first sars
and it didn't really cause that much
disturbance to everybody but now
we've all been proud that's done now
that's never going to happen again it's
never going to happen again we're going
to be much harder and stopping trying to
stop with non-pharmacological
interventions the spread of anything new
that comes and we're going to have
better monitoring systems so you don't
suddenly realize that half your
population have been infected in any
pandemic any infectious agent there are
only three types of people those that
are actually infected those that are
susceptible and those that are immune
either because they've had it or they've
been vaccinated so you've just got three
groups of people and what you want to do
is reduce the susceptible group to as
small as possible and increase the other
two growth you don't want too many
infected we want the immunized people or
the um
the natural immunity people to to go up
and reduce the susceptible and that's
that's got to be the aim
and a public inquiry going back to the
last question
could help
you know the public inquiries i've been
involved in have just been whitewashed
and
lawyers get in and they long have
produced long texts and
not much happens so i think what we need
is a
direction of travel
for
prevention of a further incident like
this ever again
it's a very very
poignant note to end them because i
think we all agree that we need an
investigation because we can't allow the
mistakes to be repeated carol thank you
so much for coming on our final question
before we've got a few questions from
our local supporters is what's the one
thing we're not talking about but we
really should be the thing we're not
talking about is still death i said that
the last time you interviewed me and age
um you know what's the value of life and
is the value of someone of your age
greater than the value of someone my age
so
that is the thing at the moment the
health service gives
doesn't use age it's
ageless but why shouldn't we use age if
you're 85 do you deserve a very high
cost cancer drug if you get cancer if we
can afford it yes but the priority has
to be for the 40 year old or the 30 year
old to get that drug and that's
something that no one likes to talk
about and
and if i do talk about it they say oh
there's a dangerous territory so why
should it be dangerous we have to make
decisions
carol thank you so much for coming on if
people want to find you online where is
the best place to do that
the best place is carol sikora
hotmail.com oh you're going to get lots
of emails
and you're on twitter of course and i'm
on twitter prof carol sicor exactly
perfect uh carol school thank you so
much for coming back and thank you all
for watching we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or or show all of them go out at 7
pm uk time or 2 p.m eastern take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below